I think if I were a lady I'd like to be
called a broad what you cuz if I were a
lady I'd be like it like a tall broad
soft okay this is the interview I've
seen your work this is one of the most
interesting things about you is you're
Jerry Garcia's daughter obviously but
you weren't really a Deadhead and you're
not really into that so I mean who
thinks what their parents do is cool no
one right like I tried really hard and
especially since they're like rock stars
but they don't look like rock star
either wearing like corduroys right you
know he paints beefy t-shirts like
where's the you know where's the leather
jumpsuit in the sequins like no they
look like roadies the roadies are
jamming and then it caught on yeah cuz
of up because of the acid cuz of the
acid they gave them sparkly outfits in
the mind's eye oh my god yeah which is a
little bit more real it's not a really
weak high-five and I don't like we did
no no don't high-five I do what you did
again it was like a class in a moment
you don't give high-fives he'd given
moments I like asking everybody haven't
gotten some psychedelics yes I have did
you do them with your dad no would he
have approved probably would have
approved and I never wanted to be high
with my parents
yeah that makes sense yeah for whatever
reason yeah I don't even want to think
about my mom hi
just flipping over cat calendars like
this is hilarious good time sorry would
your dad have scolded you or would he
have given you advice on how to like
have a good good advice yeah absolutely
advice you know they thought it was good
for Humanity and good for you know your
your spiritual development and
consciousness of of the planet which I
kind of agree like right
that's past engage oh let's talk about
your mom okay it's on this card yeah mom
is Carolyn Garcia aka mountain girl yeah
my mom's name is mountain girl that's
awesome
yep what's her deal she's awesome lady
she's uh she lives in Oregon and she was
hanging out with Ken Kesey and the Merry
Pranksters the whole electric kool-aid
acid test that they were like riding
around the country on a bus high on acid
um in the early 60s make the flaming
lips look like Mormons pretty much yeah
yeah yeah and these were that was like
your extended family was the the cool a
well seeing Ken Kesey's you know my is
like an uncle to me so grew up with a
lot of really over-the-top
psychedelic personalities that sounds
awesome
yeah was it in retrospect yeah yes super
cool like way cooler than TV dinners and
and church on Sunday yeah you know let
me tell you you're right your mom she
did acid yeah both my parents did acid
do breastfeeding yeah she probably did
acid when she's pregnant me like
whatever you know like things were so
different then I'm fine I'm okay that's
not a big deal you look over here I'm
just not here I'm on the Pete home shows
[Music]